foreign
hey what's up everybody it is September
10th 2021 I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report direct message we are now
roughly four and a half days away from
the recall of Gavin Newsom I'm psyched
I think I was fired up yesterday people
said Dave you're normally come you're an
even keeled guy you help keep me sane
you were fired up yesterday well I'm
fired up today we'll see which way I can
channel the energy and guys look at this
shirt have you ever seen a better
looking shirt in your life recall
Newsome and you know with the picture of
a man that the Los Angeles Times calls
the black face of white supremacy so
will YouTube stop this stream will they
delete my channel will they ban me and
demonetize me for having a white
supremacist t-shirt on the show we shall
find out I'll also get back to the LA
Times in just a minute uh there is a ton
going on unfortunately we're going to
have to talk a bit about kovid and these
mandates because basically all hell
broke loose yesterday like if you think
things have been bad with government
overreach and just the endless extension
of the state into every part of your
life well Biden or the shell that Biden
is with whoever is pulling the strings
they just ramped up just getting
involved in every single part of your
life with these mandates that are going
to go through the federal government
they're going to go through companies
with more than 100 employees which of
course is completely arbitrary and
that's just the first step before they
get to companies that were much smaller
and much more that and by the way we've
got video of of course Biden saying he'd
never do it and Pelosi saying he'd never
do it etc etc so that's Story number one
story number two we're going to get you
caught up on everything uh recall
related I'm going to talk more about the
LA times they have written not only that
Larry Elder is the black face of white
supremacy but they have a couple other
headlines about Larry Elder about that
woman the white woman and the monkey
mask who threw the egg at him and the
way they frame the story actually made
it sound like Larry Elder was being the
violent one will juxtapose a couple
headlines for you and then I've just got
like three videos of AOC being an idiot
and we'll just we'll just play them
quick and then after the show they today
we're going to vote he's going to vote
I'm going to vote this guy's going to
vote David's going to vote we're all
going to vote and we're going to show up
and vote in person I know Gavin Newsom I
know you don't want people to vote in
person but we are going to vote in
person oh and I should mention that in
the Larry Elder segment that we're going
to do the recall segment segment number
two uh we're also going to cover the
video that we put up yesterday I had
Rose McGowan on Rose McGowan is the
actress who basically took down Harvey
Weinstein right like she was the hero of
the feminists for fighting the
patriarchy stopping this horrific serial
rapist etc etc well on the show
yesterday
she claimed that she met with the wife
of Gavin Newsom Gavin newsom's current
wife Jennifer Newsom on behalf of David
Boyce who was Harvey Weinstein's lawyer
to see what they could do to get Rose to
go away basically pay her off so that
the Harvey Weinstein story wouldn't
happen this was about three months
before the Weinstein story broke that is
an incredible accusation Rose says she
has the receipts on it I may or may not
have seen such receipts and nobody in
the mainstream media is picking up it
was picked up of course by The Blaze and
the daily wire and post-millennial Real
Clear Politics actually I just saw that
Brett Bear over at Fox News retweeted it
but one of the sick twisted uh ways that
Society is crumbling right now is that
the media does not do their job when it
doesn't fit their narrative they really
want Newsome to be in power right that's
why Obama's doing ads and uh kamala's
here and and they're sending you know
aoc's doing videos and everything else
so they They Don't Care About Women in
this case when the wife of the governor
is trying to pay off a rape victim of
Harvey Weinstein can't get that to get
to mainstream yet so we're going to keep
pushing it and I'm I'm doing my best on
Twitter anyway we'll get to all that
before we get to any of this stuff guys
I want to talk to you about Marley spoon
you know now that I'm back on the grid
it's time to get back to normal normal
and that means back to busy I'm looking
forward to simplifying my kitchen
routine with Martha Stewart and Marley
spoon America's best tasting meal kit
sign up today with code Reuben and get a
hundred bucks off your first four boxes
Martha Stewart and Marley spoon deliver
quick and convenient meals designed by
chefs to be ready in about 30 minutes
the ready to heat meals are ready in
under five minutes the subscription is
always flexible so you can skip your
skip or pause whenever you want and
orders can be customized every week to
suit tastes and special diets whether
you're looking for kid-friendly
favorites like pizza and Tacos
adventurous and flavorful dishes from
around the world or desserts breakfast
or smoothies Martha Stewart and Marley
spoon have got you covered you all know
I love to cook and pull out all the
stops but it's also nice sometimes to
have someone else put together
everything for you I was scrolling
through the menu online this morning and
there really are some great looking
dishes they've got this Oktoberfest
smoked cheddar currywurst that looks
incredible uh Michael over here was
drooling he was drooling over the
Harissa honey roasted eggplant stop
drooling Michael and they've got this
German sunken apple cake with whipped
sour cream just to top it all off and
those are just some of my options for
this week so if you're like me and tired
of Rush meals and boring dinners let
Martha Stewart and Marley spoon change
that go to marthaspoon.com and use promo
code Reuben to get 100 bucks off your
first order that's 100 bucks of free
food just for using promo code Reuben
it's a game changer everything's
delicious everything's ready fast and
everybody including my own crew
apparently wants to return for seconds
check them out at marleysmoon.com and
now back to me little Insider knowledge
for you guys by the way uh little known
fact I actually was a PA a production
assistant on MAR uh Martha Stewart's
talk show when she got out of jail
remember she had that talk show for
about 10 years and for about two seasons
I was a PA on that show I once was in a
room alone with Martha Stewart and she
had me adjust her chair so there you go
uh okay let's talk
important stuff you know all right let's
talk about vaccines and the mandates and
everything else there's a lot
of craziness going on so first I want to
show you this video of a reporter asking
Jen saki Miss I could not tell the truth
if my life depended on it asking her
whether the Administration has authority
to force private companies to mandate
vaccines and my God I think she actually
said something she believes here take a
look to use your word how bold is the
president willing to be as far as the
private sector is concerned than the
vaccine the Mandate area even if they
don't have
of federal contracts can the Department
of Labor or anybody else compel major
employers the larger employers to force
the vaccine mandates on their employees
yes stay tuned more to come this
afternoon go ahead
so I don't know if that's true that
Biden actually has the Constitutional
power to do it but at least she's being
honest like yes we're going to do it
we're going to force companies to do it
and as we're going to get to momentarily
they now are forcing companies with over
100 employees do it or at least they're
trying to force companies with over a
hundred employees to force everyone to
get vaccinated I just want to say to you
two sitting in this room right now that
um you know I know I'm a benevolent
leader around here but I'm never going
to force you to be injected with
anything to work here so you're welcome
uh yeah I got a thumbs up that's nice
um so that's one thing so yes she says
and she smiles when she says it because
these people really love power and if
you don't think they love power well
here's uh old Joe talking about how he
plans to use power
and all school officials trying to do
the right thing by our children
I'll always be on your side let me be
blunt
my plan also takes on elected officials
and states that are undermining you
and these life-saving actions
right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe in a pandemic while
their governor
picks a fight with them and even
threatens their salaries or their jobs
talk about bullying in schools
if thou not help if these Governors
won't help speed the pandemic I'll use
my power as president to get them out of
the way
I will use my power as president to get
them out of the way does that sound like
the president of the United States at
least the United States that I used to
know or does that sound like a dictator
I will use my power as president to get
them out of the way now I do want to
give credit where credit is due you know
I always try to do that Joe actually was
able to read the teleprompter there he
obviously has dementia and we all know
it and there's a huge problem with his
cognitive abilities but he did read that
one without mumbling and stuttering over
it so I will give him credit for that
but that line I'll use my Powers person
to get them out of the way is probably
the most dangerous thing I've ever heard
a president say in my lifetime
please show me where Donald Trump said
something that dangerous that the
federal government will impede on the
state's rights to make decisions for
themselves by the way that is
unconstitutional we have something here
called the Federalist system right and
each state is supposed to make the rules
for itself now maybe none of this works
anymore right like maybe that's where
we're at that the constitution is a
piece of paper that we're supposed to be
governed by the Bill of Rights are a
series of laws to protect us and protect
our god-given rights but maybe they just
sit on paper and now the machine the
evil machine that is this Administration
and that's the only way I can describe
it has decided we're not going to abide
by any of those things and there's
obviously no one in the media that's
going to stand up against them the media
will actually cheer it on uh and there's
really no one politically I mean there's
a couple there's a couple decent people
right so I think it was can we get the
number on this I think around 14 or 17
Republican Governors said they're going
to stand up against this but what does
Biden mean are you going to send in
federal troops to take over these states
maybe maybe I mean does that sound crazy
what what would be too crazy for this
Administration I don't think there's
anything that would be too crazy for
this administration at this point we'll
get you the exact number on the
Republicans uh the Republican Governors
who said they're not going to abide by
this by the way there's also a
spectacular video by Jeremy boring of
the daily wire they do have over 100
employees I have two companies we don't
have over a hundred yet
um but they do have over a hundred and
he said he will not force anyone that
works for him uh to get the vaccine he
said he himself is vaccinated and that
he believes in vaccines but he's just
not going to do it and they're looking
into all the the legal recourse I
believe the blaze is doing the exact
same thing uh and uh among some of the
states that are threatening to fight
back in our Texas Missouri Georgia I
have no doubt that DeSantis in Florida
but I think that I think that about 17
Governors if I'm not mistaken now if you
think all of that is nuts well let's
just look at some video from some of the
Democrats saying that they would never
require anyone to be vaccinated here's
skeletor-like Nancy Pelosi
no I don't think it should be mandatory
I wouldn't demand to be mandatory there
will be no Nationwide mandate I was
referring to mandates by private
institutions and portions of the federal
government there will be no federal
mandate one that's not the role of the
Federal Government I don't think you'll
ever see a mandating of vaccine
particularly for the general public but
you would never mandate at least I do
not think you would I'd be pretty
surprised if you mandated it for any
element of the General Public
all right sorry about that we got the
the clips backwards there uh so fauci
Biden sake and the head of the CDC all
saying that we'll never have Federal
mask mandates now do we have the Pelosi
one we've got the Pelosi one here's
Nancy Pelosi
so here's the thing we are we cannot
require someone to be vaccinated that's
just not what we can do
it is a matter of privacy to know who is
or who isn't
we cannot require someone to be
vaccinated that's what she said months
ago and she talks about privacy and we
do have some privacy laws in the United
States so again I don't know that any of
the laws work I don't know that any of
it matters anymore I don't know that
there's enough of us that will stand up
I'm doing what I can a few other people
are
um but these are their words so Nancy so
if we had journalists right if we had
journalists and not journalists what
would somebody be doing next time they
saw Nancy Pelosi at the ice cream store
getting a haircut what they would say to
her is Nancy Nancy you know a few months
ago you said that we cannot force people
to be vaccinated you didn't say we
should not or I don't want to you said
we cannot that implies that there's laws
that allow for medical privacy and it's
and my body my choice and people want to
make decisions for themselves and their
family so what changed because old
dementia Joe decided to have this
Federal Mass mandate for all federal
employees and get this one I mean this
is just the Ridiculousness if you don't
think that these people are utter clowns
and abject buffoons they are mandating
vaccines to all federal employees which
I think is something like can we get the
number how many federal employees I
think it's around 2 million or so but
they are exempting the postal workers
there's about 650 000 postal workers I
think so that everyone has to do it
except we're putting an exemption on the
postal workers
guys the postal workers are the ones who
come to everybody's house who touch all
your stuff and then you pick it up so
I'm not
2.1 million federal workers and about
650 000 post workers so it's all just
absolutely nonsensical uh by the way
this made me all think all the way back
to July and I know none of us have
memories anymore but something you know
I was off the grid for a month so my
memory has been a little sharper lately
I've been able to reorganize things in
my brain and I thought wait a minute
wait a minute wasn't there some guy
named Dave Rubin who got suspended on
Twitter right before I went off the grid
some real right-wing Freedom loving
Maniac because he said something about
oncoming Federal Mass mandates and then
you're not going to believe this we
found this screenshot this is this is
nuts so some guy I don't know who this
is Dave Rubin at Ruben report whatever
the hell that is and he said they want a
federal vaccine mandate for vaccines
which are clearly not working as
promised just weeks ago people are
getting and transmitting covid despite
the vax plus now they are preparing us
for booster shots saying society would
take pause we do not live in a sane
Society you're not going to believe this
so again I have no idea who this nut bag
is but he got suspended for about 24
hours on Twitter for that for saying
that a federal Mass mandate is coming
for saying that vaccines aren't working
as promised those things are obviously
true uh and that you know we're going to
need more booster shots according to
these people and that's happening right
now uh Twitter did from what I
understand unban him and said it was an
error but you know a guy like that
should not in my opinion should not be
allowed to be on social media because
you know he can't be ahead of the curve
you know what I mean like you gotta fall
in line man you can't just say the truth
and then just wait around I don't like
that guy can we let's find out who he is
and send him a strongly worded letter
all right guys before we move to Story
number two I want to talk to you about
Uprising food you know you all know how
much I love food I just told you a
little bit about it a moment ago and for
those of you who've been tuning into my
show over the past couple years you know
that I've had various guests who've
talked all about how our food system is
fundamentally broken and making us sick
at scale well fortunately the people at
Uprising food are fixing that uprising's
mission is to liberate all of us from a
broken food system that's stealing our
health they have cracked the code on
healthy bread you simply can't find
something this healthy that tastes this
good that's this fresh I received the
starter bundler sampler and please don't
make me choose between the sea salt
chips and the Rye chips I can't do it I
have them they're good I'm just so happy
to have both with these two net carbs
per serving two grams of protein and
nine grams of fiber Uprising food covers
paleo to clean keto to simple low carb
high fiber to dairy free to grain free
Lifestyles all Uprising products are
baked with real super food ingredients
almonds
MCT oil apple cider apple cider vinegar
egg white psyllium husk and olive oil
Uprising has absolutely nailed the taste
Factor on both of their sourdough s
cubes and the crunch Factor on their
newly launched Freedom chips there's a
name which tastes like those old school
Rye chips you dig basically if you're a
bio hacker and a if a biohacker and a
high-end farmer's market Baker had a
baby it'd be these Uprising products go
to uprisingfood.com and use code Reuben
to get 10 off the starter bundle it's
kind of like a mini trip to the grocery
store minus all the unhealthy
distractions and they ship directly to
your door of course that's
uprisingfood.com and use my code Reuben
for ten dollars off your first order and
now back to me okay let's talk about the
man on my shirt right here Mr Larry
Elder he's getting a lot of momentum he
was on Tucker Carlson last night you
know obviously there was this ridiculous
incident with the with the monkey woman
and the Egg and it's like you don't want
anything like that to happen but at
least it did bring attention to his
campaign that's good obviously the
Democrats are nervous because they're
bringing out the big guns Obama and
Kamala and I think Biden is doing
something today supposedly and as I said
yesterday look if it's Gavin Newsom
Barack Obama and Kamala Harris and now
Joe Biden versus Larry Elder me and
Scott Baio
I like our chances we're going to be all
right
um so first I want to show you these two
headlines this is this is just really
like if you want to see how perverse
really perverse and dishonest the
mainstream media is these are two of the
headlines from the Los Angeles Times
this is the Los Angeles Times the same
Los Angeles Times who by the way as you
know said that Larry Elder is putting is
the blackface uh on white supremacy okay
so look at these two headlines now you
all know what happened the other day
this crazy woman that you're seeing
there with the pink gorilla mask she
started screaming uh racist remarks and
cursing at Larry and a whole bunch of
other people were saying really horrific
things at Larry as he was just walking
through Venice because Venice has become
a drug den and a homeless encampment
basically so she's throwing a negative
she then assaulted one of the um
one of the security guards and look how
they framed it Larry Elder Cuts short
Venice homeless encampment tour after
hostile reception and then look at the
second one now first off the first one
hostile reception the implication is
that he's getting a hostile reception
like from sane people right like like he
got there and he said something that
then they were hostile about but these
were crazy drug addicts and Maniacs but
the important what they're trying to do
is frame it is that he's somehow
controversial that that first one's not
terrible actually but I want to show you
the second one which is really just it's
just remarkable LAPD is investigating
altercation involving Larry Elder at
Venice homeless encampment
what does that sound like to you if you
didn't know this story it sounds like
Larry Elder picked a fight probably with
a homeless person at a homeless
encampment that is so deeply dishonest
it's it's just it's pure
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it is and the L the
the LA times at this point is a white
supremacist newspaper I can only deduce
that between you know basically calling
him a white supremacist lying about this
violent attack not saying that you know
what where are all their op-eds about
the racist base of the democratic party
that's throwing eggs and attacking a
black candidate you know where where's
all of that so I guess the LA Times is a
white supremacist newspaper there's sort
of No Way Around It that being said I
still am feeling good about what's
happening with the recall and I get it
you know I really want to make this
point clear well two points here
actually first off I get it the deck is
stacked against us this is this is
largely a democratic State and modern
liberals no matter how many times you
whack them in the head with reality uh
it's very hard for them to go oh all of
the reasons the state sucks the high
taxes High regulation bad schools bad
roads homelessness drug use Etc it's
it's hard to believe that that could
have anything to do with the way I've
been voting right uh this is like sort
of what I would say to Bill Maher if
he's ever brave enough to put me on the
show it's like you rail against all of
these things all day long you're a good
liberal right my good my good liberal
friends what happened to my IDW good
liberals they've all gone silent on
everything that matters uh and I do want
to give a complete exception to that on
Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson who have
been as good as ever but the Liberals
have just completely completely
collapsed
um so let's uh also show you because
we're talking about the media and Larry
Elder here this this video from
yesterday now I know some of you have
seen this yesterday but Rose McGowan was
on the show Rose McGowan is the girl who
in effect single-handedly took down
Harvey Weinstein she walked through the
fire said this man raped me it started
uncovering all of the other horrific
rapes and sexual assaults that Harvey
Weinstein did two years ago he was the
biggest bad guy in America right like
that was the thing it started the metoo
movement you know believe all women all
of that stuff well now Rose McGowan is
coming out and saying that Gavin
newsom's wife Jen Newsome three months
before the Harvey Weinstein story broke
when they knew it was going to break
that she contacted rose on behalf of
Harvey Weinstein's lawyer to see what
could make the story go away and she's
saying she has receipts do you think
that maybe that's worthy of the news
covering it right now that the
California governor who's under recall
that his wife was Shilling for Harvey
Weinstein to silence someone who was
sexually assaulted by Harvey Weinstein
like do you think that maybe that's
newsworthy maybe well first in case you
haven't seen it here's Rose Jennifer
siebold Newsom I think that is her name
yes she called me and she set up a
meeting with me to meet her somewhere in
Brentwood and I actually went and I got
very like creeped out and I saw her
sitting where our system meter and I
looked at her and I I turned around and
went back into my car and drove away she
wanted to meet me when is this when is
this just it's just about uh six months
before the New York Times Times article
on Weinstein that I set up broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
theranos board member the uh lawyer for
a long time lawyer of Hillary and Bill
and um Clinton and Weinstein one David
Boyce so this woman I don't know some
blonde lady named with the last name of
Newsome cold calls me and he's like
David Boyce wants to know what it would
take to make you happy
six months before the Weinstein story
what it would take to make you happy
which you took as for those that might
be playing along a little bit slowly
absolutely nothing would make me happy
what would it take to make you happy
this guy was raping you for years raping
all kinds of people he's the most evil
man in America the entire system uh
tells you how awful he is you know he
should burn in hell blah blah blah
believe all women it started an actual
revolution in this country in some
respects but now that's this story is
not being covered now I do want to
clarify two things here uh in that video
there she said uh six months before the
story broke she later clarified with me
yesterday after we taped the show that
it was three months before the New York
Times ran the Harvey Weinstein story so
that's just it's not that important but
it's worth mentioning uh and also if you
watch the full interview originally
Jennifer Newsom wanted a in-person
meeting
with rose rose actually went saw her
sitting there and then didn't go and
then this was all done on a phone call
Rose is saying she has receipts and I'm
not saying I haven't have not seen
receipts
um but where are you media where are you
Media or Gavin
Jennifer come out and say she's a liar
is she a liar
where are you gav come on
speaking of liars I want to end the show
today with three videos from AOC and I
think I'm going to cover these in a very
special way just with one line each
because I'm going to let AOC the Wonder
Woman of intellectual genius I'm gonna
let her words stand on their own video
one
well I certainly don't think it's
healthy that Exxon Mobil lobbyists are
bragging about how many senators
Democrat and Republican that they get to
have speed on speed dial and enjoy
exclusive access to shaping The Contours
of this quote-unquote bipartisan
infrastructure bill I don't think that
that's healthy at all I think the role
of dark money and the and the fossil
fuel Lobby is extremely unhealthy for
our democracy but the fact of the matter
is is that we've got the people on on
our side and this is what we continue to
say you know they have money these
lobbyists and and special interests have
money but we've got people the build
back better act has popular support and
even going above and beyond that the
green New Deal has popular support even
among Republicans and independents and
so what what people I think are united
behind is the acknowledgment that
climate change is human caused that the
burning of fossil fuels and the
continued construction of fossil fuel
infrastructure like what we're seeing
with line three in Minnesota must be
confronted if we're going to create a
better future for ourselves
yeah the green New Deal has popular
support even among Republicans and
independents AOC you're a liar next when
we talk about
um
the law that was passed in Texas we know
that anti-choice bills are not about
being pro-life because if they were
about being pro-life
then the Republican Party would support
frankly an agenda that helps guaranteed
health care that helps ensure that
people who do give birth that don't have
the resources to care for a child can
have that care for a child so we know
that none of this is about life none of
this is about supporting life what this
is about is controlling women's bodies
and controlling people who are not
cisgender men this is about making sure
that someone like me as a woman or any
menstruating person in this country
cannot make decisions over their own
body and people like Governor Abbott and
Mitch McConnell want to have more
control over over a woman's body than
that woman or that person has over
themselves and what what that shares in
in you know what that shares with rape
culture is that sexual assault is about
the abuse of power and sexual assault is
about asserting control over another
person and the ease with which these men
seek to do that to other people is
atrocious
AOC in that video in case you weren't
playing paying attention called women
people who give birth then she called
them women and then she called them any
menstruating person thus AOC you're a
transphobic [ __ ] clip three yes now
listen if you live in California there's
probably a ballot in your mailbox on a
recall election please find that thing
vote no stick that sucker right back in
your mailbox because the options are
back
AOC just get the [ __ ] out of my state
you buffoon we don't want you here we
don't care what you think and we're
going to do what we think is right but
because you are so rabidly against a
decent black man becoming governor of
the great state of California the once
great state I should say uh you are a
right-wing racist white supremacist
congratulations AOC guys part three of
my interview with Tucker Carlson and I
promise you promise you promise you this
is Tucker Carlson like you've never
heard him before part three is up right
now on YouTube went up this morning the
full episode of course is up already
absolutely ad-free at
reubenreport.locals.com and guess where
we're going now guys
we're going to vote that's right we are
going to vote will I get kicked out of
the polling station for wearing this
shirt I will bring I know there might be
some like rule about you can't wear a
pin or a shirt or a hat that's promoting
anyone so I'm going to try to go like
this and then you know if they say
something to me I'll bring a hoodie and
I'll cover it up uh but I do want to say
uh as I close the show that I've never
been more proud to vote for someone as I
will be when I walk into that Booth
today Larry is a good decent man who as
I said yesterday he doesn't really want
to be Governor because he doesn't want
to be governor in that he doesn't want
to solve all your problems he wants to
be Governor because this thing is so
freaking broken because it's so out of
control and you know it's very obvious
to me that America needs a massive shock
to the system if everything that I
talked about on the show day AOC is an
idiot the media is awful all this
coveted stuff and mandates and people
that are now don't know what to do
because they don't want to lose their
jobs but they also don't want to get a
vaccine for whatever reason they don't
want to when they're young and healthy
or whatever it might be if all of this
seems horrible to you and it is horrible
like it really is it is whether I can
occasionally joke about it or not like
this is this is bad stuff like the creep
of Socialism or communism or just
authoritarianism whatever you want to
call it it's here it's on our Shores
it's been ushered in by the Liberals and
the media it's it's it's terrible it is
here there's no doubt about it but you
know there's always hope humans always
have hope humans have always been
through bad things and things have
gotten better but at some point enough
of us have to say no I will no longer
participate in this lie uh you know I
think I mentioned the other day that one
of the movies we watched
during uh time off the grid was Cloud
Atlas and it's a really interesting
movie by the Wachowski brothers who did
V for Vendetta and they did The Matrix
and a whole bunch of other stuff and the
line the main line in the movie is I
will not be subjected to criminal abuse
and it's a theme throughout many decades
and Hundred Year periods actually
thousand year periods in the movie you
have to see the movie to fully
understand what I'm saying but it's in
in essence is oh the LIE stops with me
the lie stops with me and lies are
everywhere and encroaching power is
everywhere and we need some hope that's
the point like we need something like I
think a lot of people are just like man
everything is collapsing all around us
and you're kind of right like I'm not
going to sit here and say you're not
right but there is hope and you know as
goes California goes the nation well
then let's fix California so please if
you're in California do the right thing
and vote Yes on the recall and then vote
for Larry Elder or at least vote Yes on
the recall and then if you want to vote
for somebody else so be it I think my
feelings about Larry are clear but
imagine imagine if on Tuesday just a
couple days from now imagine if it
happened imagine if it happened a blow
to the machine you know what I mean like
if it took a hit and then suddenly
people were like holy cow California
isn't on the endless descent to hell and
then other people in other states would
suddenly feel good and feel more
empowered and feel like Oh I'm a decent
human being maybe there's something I
can do whether it's run for governor or
stand up at a school board or fight for
what I believe in however it is that I
can do it we just need a signal and I
really think that this situation right
now on Tuesday is a signal and maybe
maybe it will be that on Wednesday I'm
going to be pretty damn depressed when
I'm in this room maybe it will be but
that's not a reason not to fight so
please fight with me however you can
electelder.com they need a couple bucks
to finish strong here unfortunately
politics is about money and trust me I
know I've talked to Larry privately
enough like the idea of asking for money
is ridiculous and he doesn't want to do
it so I'll do it for them there you go
electelder.com and let's let's see if we
can get to something with a little hope
I have hope do you have hope
um all right have a good weekend
everybody we're gonna go you know maybe
we'll do some videos can we do some
videos maybe on the way or yeah all
right so we'll do some videos on the way
I don't think we're they're gonna let us
do videos at the polling place but I'm
I'm sorry and do it guys recall this
prick and let's get Larry Elder to be
the next governor of California have a
great weekend everybody and if you want
to play along with food and music and
all that stuff reubenreport.locals.com